-I want to ask this, as well,
which is a cool --
you know, obviously, paying
homage to the original film,
you are -- you're playing
a character
who apprenticed
under Dick Van Dyke's...
-Yeah. I was his intern.
-His intern.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-And -- And Dick Van Dyke
was in the film.
-Yeah.
-And 91 years old.
And I -- it sounds,
from -- from what I've read,
that he is exactly the way
he's always been.
-He's got the glint in his eye
that he has had
his entire career.
And they asked a lot of him.
They -- He has a tap solo
on top of a desk.
And I remember,
the week before,
you know,
we had contingency plans
of, like,
"If he can't get up on the desk,
maybe you get under his leg.
Emily, you're spotting.
If Dick Van Dyke falls,
he's falling on either
Emily Blunt or Lin Miranda."
-Yeah.
-Like, "We're not gonna let that
guy -- That is precious cargo.
You're not letting him
touch the ground."
So, we had all these plans
sort of in place.
And then, he came in,
and he was just --
I mean, he is --
he's human caffeine.
-Yeah.
-He literally was like,
"When I was 30,
I was playing 90.
And now I'm 90,
and I'm playing 80."
[ Laughter ]
Like, the greatest.
And then,
we rehearsed the scene,
and I, like,
offered him my hand.
He slaps it away
and just goes, like...
♪♪ Da, da, da, da ♪♪
I mean, it was crazy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-I...
-One deep lunge.
-I mean, I can't even imagine
because he's 91 -- you're not,
and I was terrified
when you got on my desk.
[ Laughter ]
It was like, I can't --
Lin can't hurt himself here.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-And then I heard Meryl Streep
took a fall,
but a different kind of fall.
-Yes.
So I asked -- listen,
working with Meryl Streep
is, like,
not a thing you get to do
on your first movie ever, ever.
-No.
-But Emily -- it was her --
Emily's third movie.
And I sort of asked her,
"What it's like?"
And she sort of, like, she's
sort of kind of in the character
that she's playing
the whole time.
And she said on
"Devil Wears Prada,"
she basically barely talked
to Meryl until it was up
because they were very
contentious in that movie.
But in our movie,
she, like, is a delight.
And she's kind of always
showing off for the kids.
And she showed off for the kids.
And at one point,
she turned to the kids --
This is between takes.
This is on the rehearsal.
She goes, "Hey, kids,
want to see a perfect pratfall?"
And she goes from here
to facedown, like --
like Chevy Chase 1975 pratfall.
[ Laughter ]
And, like, just on her face.
And everyone runs over.
"Meryl Streep
has died on our set!"
[ Laughter ]
And she gets up.
And she goes like this.
"I learned that
at Yale School of Drama."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-And it was just the coolest --
coolest thing ever.
[ Applause ]
-They -- They say --
They say of all the Ivies,
Yale is the pratfall school.
-That's the pratfall school.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This is really exciting.
You are gonna get back onstage
to do "Hamilton" in Puerto Rico.
-That's right.
-In January.
-Yes. I have
my first rehearsal tomorrow.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, no, you didn't
get a break at all.
-Yeah.
-When you say --
I mean, first rehearsal,
how -- do you -- do you --
I mean, it will
come back quickly, yes?
-I think so.
-Yeah.
-I mean, our --
So, our incredible new company,
which is -- this is
the third national tour
that will premiere
in Puerto Rico.
We'll raise as much money
as we can for Puerto Rico,
and then it goes on
to tour the United States.
They've been rehearsing
for five weeks.
I have been talking about
"Mary Poppins."
-[ Laughing ] Right, yeah.
-And so I'll join them
and sort of stumble through --
emphasis on the "stumble"...
-Uh-huh.
-...tomorrow.
And it's all in there.
It's sort of like --
I think it's --
You know, I think of my brain
as like a desktop
with too many apps open.
I just have to
clean up the files.
I never hit "Empty trash"
at any point.
[ Laughter ]
They're all there.
-Good.
-I just have to remember.
-And the --
This is very exciting.
Jimmy Fallon is taking
"The Tonight Show"
to Puerto Rico, as well.
-He is.
-You're gonna be a guest on
that show, which is really --
-Yeah, yeah. We're gonna do
a special show from Puerto Rico,
which is really exciting.
-I think that's really cool.
And it's great
that you're raising money.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-And just in general,
congratulations on everything.
-Thank you so much.
-And so happy to have you back.
-Give it up, everybody.